ce matin j'étais sur megaupload pour
télécharger le film de vacances de mes
parents non je déconne c'est téléchargé
illégalement un film parce que j'aime
tuer l'industrie du cinéma
bref j'étais sur mes gueux fun et je
regardais les publicités qu'ils avaient
sur le site et j'ai perdu foi en
l'humanité
mon top 5 des pubs que j'ai pu croiser
tu veux me voir nue
attention c'est pas tu veux la voir nue
c'est tu veux me voir nue genre il
existerait une fille sur terre
absolument bonne qui a envie de faire un
petit sondage comme ça en mettant sa
photo pour savoir si les gens ont envie
quoi sondage absolument pas biaisé par
cet énorme paire de nichons
non mais sérieux c'est quoi cette pub un
qui va cliquer sur non et même si tu
cliques sur non il se passe quoi non
félicitations vous êtes homosexuel
sérieux autre genre la pub que j'ai
croisé le plus souvent la plus moche et
la moins française aussi le secret pour
perdre du poids a découvert il avait le
choix entre à découvrir où a été
découvert mais non il faut qu'ils
s'occupent acte le mix parfait d2 qu'il
veut rien dire
un verre la phrase qui suit n'est pas
aimé non plus j'ai perdu deux kilos par
semaine de grèce non malheureusement
dans la langue française on peut pas
mettre les mots d'ordre qu'on veut c'est
comment dans la lignée des questions
débiles
tu veux une copine sexy non non non non
je veux une copine dégueulasse édenté
bien grosse avec des croûtes entre les
bourrelets un oeil de verre et qui boite
pourquoi nous prennent pour des cons
une bulle pour un fortifiant musculaire
on est bien d'accord
une pub c'était pour donner envie qui
envie de ressembler à ce monstre sérieux
c'est une blague
les mêmes qui ont fait 7 pubis qu'ils
ont rien compris voilà pour la pub j'ai
pensé à cette photo au super lagarde
je savais qu'elle était à ça et pour
finir ma publicité préférée impossible
de la louper elle est énorme
lisez bien la première phrase et c'est
quand la dernière que tu as eu une fille
aussi sexy il manque un mot dans la
phrase incroyable ça manque quand même
que les mecs sont bat les couilles de la
publicité c'est la première pub que je
vois où il manque un mot quand même
l'oréal parce que je le bien coupé il
manque un mot mur lagarde
voilà c'était juste une petite vidéo
bonus que vous pouvez partager sur
facebook et vous pouvez retrouver toutes
mes autres vidéos sur six points et perd
aussi à bientôt
et même si tu piques surnom il se passe
quoi charles pasqua